el libro capital en el siglo 21 de
thomas piketty ha estado recibiendo
mucha atención últimamente porque aborda
un problema que es importante para
muchas personas y este es la desigualdad
en el ingreso y en la riqueza mi
objetivo aquí es usar este libro como
una herramienta para darles las
habilidades de pensamiento crítico
necesarias para que ustedes saquen sus
propias conclusiones
una cosa muy buena de este libro es que
su autor hace públicas todas sus
gráficas y esquemas en su sitio web http
dos puntos diagonal diagonal piquet y
punto p s punto n ese punto efe rr
diagonal en diagonal capital 21 c 2 así
que todas las gráficas que veremos son
de este sitio web los invito a que
visiten este sitio por su cuenta y
revisen las gráficas que ahí están ya
que tienen información muy interesante
aunque vean las con mente abierta y ojo
crítico para que estén atentos a qué
cosas tienen sentido cuáles no lo tienen
tanto y qué preguntas pueden surgir al
respecto las cuales ustedes quisieran
analizar con más detalle comencemos con
esta gráfica de aquí aquí comenzamos a
ver algo que podría ser un problema esta
se llama desigualdad de riqueza en eeuu
de 1810 al 2010
aquí miren la riqueza como la
participación en el primer decil o
percentil de la riqueza total esta parte
de acá es el 1% superior de
participación de riqueza que
este de acá y este otro nos indica el
primer decir el 10% de participación de
riqueza este punto que coloreó en
magenta quiere decir que en 1810 el 1%
de los más ricos tenían aproximadamente
el 25 por ciento de la riqueza total del
país y el 10% de los más ricos tenían un
casi el 60 por ciento de la riqueza
total del país podemos ver como estas
líneas se van comportando desde el siglo
19 hasta el inicio del siglo 20 en
particular tenemos este periodo de las
últimas dos décadas del siglo 19 las
cuales se conocen como la edad dorada la
cual está asociada con una dramática
desigualdad en la riqueza
y la pregunta que se hacen en este libro
es si estamos entrando a otra edad
dorada si vemos esta tendencia de acá es
evidente que la desigualdad en la
riqueza no es tan severa como la primera
edad dorada pero está la cuestión de
hacia dónde va esto y si es que a la
gente debería preocuparle esto esta
línea se comportará como en la edad
dorada haciendo algo como esto
algo que se parezca más a la gráfica de
la edad dorada o quizás hará algo así o
incluso algo así y si es que ocurriera
el primer escenario tendríamos las
mismas realidades que tuvimos en la
primera edad dorada estas son el tipo de
preguntas que debemos analizar qué tipo
de realidad tenemos cuál es la
información o datos que nos indica el
comportamiento que seguirá y cuáles son
las decisiones políticas acerca de cosas
como la innovación o impuestos o
educación que podrían llevarnos a un
escenario oa otro
veremos todas estas ideas con mayor
detalle durante los siguientes vídeos de
esta serie